- Good job buddy, thank you!
- You're going to put this on YouTube?
- Yeah, it's going to be on
YouTube! We have a million subs.
- I'm going to be on YouTube!
- Let's go.
(Jazz Music)
- I promise I've tested this many times.
If you've seen my recent
"Facing Fears" video,
you know I just came back
from Kissimmee, Florida.
I also have a type of partnership
with Kissimmee, Florida.
So, while I was there vacationing,
enjoying my time facing my fears,
I decided to do one of my favorite things
and do a curbside consult
Kissimmee edition.
I literally ran around the
streets of Kissimmee, Florida
answering people's questions.
Here's what happened:
- (Participant) I was wondering today,
if blood's true color was blue.
It's only because of oxygen that it's red.
- That's a great question.
So in your veins, the reason
why you see the blue tint
is because the blood is
slightly deoxygenated
so it has a bluish tint.
But in reality blood is still red.
It's true when we draw our text books
and our anatomy pictures,
we always make it blue.
But that's strictly
for education purposes.
Which is the deoxygenated
blood, `which oxygenated blood
but in reality blood is still red.
So if you cut your vein,
the blood is not going to come out blue.
I promise (laughs) I've
tested this many times.
- We have another one here.
- I have a question.
- [Doctor Mike] Okay,
we got a question now!
- [Participant] Does chicken noodle soup
- [Doctor Mike] Yes?
- [Participant] good for colds
and things like that?
- Because I believe in it, that's why.
Is it good for a common cold?
- I swear by chicken noodle soup.
- Ashley what do you think?
- I think it's true.
- You think it's true.
Judy, what do you think?
- Yes, I do believe that.
- We just went four for four.
It's true!
Probably has something to
do with the electrolytes,
the salt, making sure you're
getting your calories,
that it's warm, it stimulates
blood flow to the area.
But it works.
- [Judy] Good job, mom!
- Good job, you got one!
- You have a medical question?
- Aspartame.
- Okay, what about aspartame.
Okay, so artificial sugars.
- Okay, is it harmful or not?
Truth be told from the
research that we have now,
harmful?
We don't yet know that it's harmful.
It's none existent yet.
Is it good for you?
Probably not.
#1 Aspartame is a lot more
sweet than regular sugar
and it conditions your
brain to want more sugar.
#2 There exists bacteria in your gut.
That bacteria loves sugar.
And that's the unhealthy
bacteria that loves the sugar.
You don't want those bacteria around
because they cause you to gain weight.
They actually influence your
cravings to want more food.
And when you eat aspartame,
you don't digest it,
so you don't get the calories and sugar
but the bacteria do.
- Whoa!
- So you increase the number
of bacteria that craves sugars
so you're going to want more sugar.
That bacteria makes you
more likely to eat more food
and get obese and all these things.
If you want something sweet occasionally,
maybe have a teaspoon of honey.
Something that brings some other benefits.
Have some apples, have some bananas.
You know things that in
addition to the sugar
will have some fiber and vitamins.
- So drink regular sodas right?
- No, no, no! I don't
want you to drink soda.
(laughing)
- If I wanna get rid of this (beep) belly
Sorry about that.
- That's okay we can bleep it.
- Perfect!
- I like that you're passionate.
- I want to delete this
but I don't have time even to walk.
- [Doctor Mike] Obviously
I'm still going to tell you
that you should make time to exercise.
- Right?
- And guess what?
It doesn't even have to be a lot of time.
If you have 15 minutes,
you can do something
known as high intensity training, right?
For 30 seconds, you go as hard as you can.
And then for two minutes,
you go slow and walk.
And if you do that cycle for 15 minutes,
that's really good exercise.
And you're going to lose some weight.
But let's forget about
exercise for a moment.
The real way to lose this,
is actually by changing your diet.
There's no one way that
works for everybody.
A couple things you can
follow, that's going to help.
Cutting the amount of calories you eat.
Sodas, sweets, pancakes,
white bread, white rice,
and even if you do a half lowering,
you don't have to stop
eating them completely.
You will see a big difference.
- Oh my god!
- [Audience] (laughing)
- I'm gorgeous!
- Maybe you as a med student,
you have a good medical question.
- Perfect! (laughs)
- Shoot! Tell me what you got.
- [Student] Your best studying technique?
- The first thing, tip that I will give is
not to worry about the test
that's coming up three tests from now.
- Okay.
- Right? Because you
have a test this week,
then you also have a test the next week,
and the next
- Exactly.
- And if you start thinking about
that whole line of testing,
you are going to go crazy
and you won't be able
to focus on this test.
- Next, is to figure
out how you learn best.
I learn very well through listening,
not so good from reading.
- So, what I would do is I
would replay my lectures,
over and over again and listen to them.
Next, you want to figure out
what the best, most efficient way
for you to learn through like
flash cards, study cards.
- Oh.
- and not just by yourself.
- Okay.
- So, it's about creating the cards
and then getting a
partner or maybe a group.
And doing it together.
Maybe you're not going to
remember the information
if it's written on a card,
but if you and your partner
talked about the concept
- Wow, that's perfect.
- you can remember
the conversation.
- And the best technique
that works in all medicine,
you'll learn this,
you'll hear it very often
- What's that?
- See one, do one, teach one.
Right?
- Okay.
- So, for you what does that mean?
That means you see the information,
- For sure.
- right?
you study the information.
Then you try and teach it to your friends.
- Big answer, huh?
- Wow, that's great!
- [Participant] When I
was pregnant with my son
- [Doctor Mike] Okay.
- [Participant] I had preeclampsia
and I developed pulmonary edema.
- Okay
- Now what is the
chances of that happening
if I have a second pregnancy.
Because you now fall into the category
of someone who had pre-eclampsia
in your first pregnancy
the odds are much more
likely that you'll have it.
That doesn't mean you'll have it for sure.
But what that means for you,
is when you go on your follow
up visits with your doctors,
when you start your next pregnancy,
you have to make sure
that they all are aware
that you've had pre-eclampsia
and that they are very stringent
in monitoring your blood pressure,
symptoms of pre-eclampsia, as you know?
- Like headaches, swelling
of the lower extremity,
high blood pressure.
Like all of these things,
need to be really carefully monitored.
Because you can technically
control it very well.
Or worst case scenario,
you can induce the pregnancy earlier on
than naturally would've.
But it will prevent you
from obviously having
true eclampsia, which is
obviously very serious.
Well I'm glad you had that question.
- Thanks!
- Thank you so much!
I love doing curbside consults.
I think it's a great way to show
that Doctors are relatable.
We're humans too.
And most importantly, answers
people's medical questions.
And questions they may be
too afraid or embarrassed
to ask their own doctor.
Now what makes this even more exciting
is that I can do a
curbside consult anywhere!
I've done it in New York City.
Now I've done it in Kissimmee.
But if you have a recommendation of
where you might think
it'd be cool that I do it,
drop it down below in the comments!
If you're enjoying the channel,
please hit subscribe.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
- I think for everyone that
has gone through hardship
through medical school,
- Like,
- Well, thank you.
- you keep us on the track, you know?
- You can make it.
I know it's hard.
It's going to be hard until we finish,
but it's all worth it.
- Awesome,
well thank you for telling me that.
I appreciate that.
- Can you tell me what
this is? It won't go away.
- Oh, common I can't diagnose
you on the street like that.
- Have you ever seen this?
- Okay, let me see.
I mean I have seen it.
Do you mind just saying on the camera
that you're cool with
this being on YouTube.
- I am.
- You're cool with it being on YouTube?
- Yeah, but I also want
to know where is Coach.
Have you seen Coach?
(Jazz Music)